اعلنت الشرطه الصوماليه ان الهجوم الذي
جنته عناصر من حركه الشباب ليله امس على
فندق بيرلا الواقع على شاطئ ليدو بمقدشو
اسفر عن مقتل سته مدنيين وثلاثه من عناصر
الشرطه بالاضافه الى سبعه من المهاجمين
وذلك في عمليه امنيه استغرقت نحو سبع
ساعات من جانبها ذكرت حركه الشباب في بيان
نشره موقع محسوب على الحركه انها قتلت في
الهجوم تسعه وعشرين ضابطا وجنديا من
القوات الحكوميه
من مقدش شو ينضم الينا مراسلنا عمر محمود
عمر ماذا بعد انتهاء هذه العمليه والمواقف
التي صدرت
نعم مريم الشرطه الصوماليه كما ذكرتم هي
التي اعلنت عن انهاء هذه المهمه الامنيه
التي استغرقت ساعات طويله من الليله
الماضيه وكان هذا الفندق الذي يقع اقل في
يقرب المصور الصوره يعني نحن الان في هذه
هي اقرب نقطه للفندق وهذا الفندق يعني تم
استهدافه من قبل مسلحي حركه المجاهدين
الذين
بداوا بالهجوم
بتفجير
انفجارين قيل انه استخدم بالرجلين كان
يحملان حزاما ناسفا بعد ذلك تمكن خمسه
منهم الى تمكن من اقتحام الفندق
والاستيلاء عليه قبل ان تصل القوات
الامنيه الصوماليه التي اشتركت مع
المسلحين وقالت انهم
انها قتلت جميع المنفذي هذا الهجوم وهناك
الروايات متضاربه بين الشرطه الصوماليه
وبين حريق شاور المجاهدين فالشرطه
الصوماليه تقول انها تمكنت ونجحت في
احتواء الهجوم قبل ان تمكن المسلحون من
قتل مزيد من المدنيين وتفجير الممتلكات
الفندق وهي التي
حاولت
تحييدهم في منطقه ضيقه في الفندق بعد ذلك
تمكن
قوات خاصه من الشرطه الصوماليه في من قتل
جميع منافذي هذا الهجوم لكن الحركه من
جانبها التنفي ذلك وتقول ان مقاتليها
تمكنوا من اقتحام الفندق والاستيلاء عليه
وقتل المزيد من من وصفاتهم باعداء الاسلام
وقالت انها قتلت اكثر من عشرين شخصا
محسوبين على الحكومه الصوماليه المعلومه
ان هذا هو اول الانفجار يحدث في هذه
المنطقه التي تعتبر انها محصنه امنيا
ويوجد فيها تواجد كبير وانتشار واسع
للقوات الصوماليه بمختلف اجزتها
وفي في اشهر قليله لم يحدث اي انفجار او
اي اختراق امني في هذه المنطقه بسبب ما
تقوم به القوات الصوماليه من تفتيشات
وعمليات امنيه واسعه في مداخل ومخارج
العاصمه الصوماليه وهذا حسب المراقبين
يعطي انباعا ان تهديد الذي تمثله الحركه
ما يزال قائما بسبب وصول مسلحين منهم في
هذه المنطقه التي تقع والمضله على شاطئ
الليدو وهو شادي يذهب اليها المواطنون
والمسؤولين العسكري الحكوميون في ايام
العضله من اجل اخذ الاستراحه
والتنفيذ من سخب الحياه لكن الى الان
الحكومه الصوماليه تصر على انها
نجحت كثيرا في تامين العاصمه الصوماليه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه عمر محمود من مقديشه
شكرا جزيلا لك